chante beven a fondé le réseau en
juillet dernier depuis l'aube avec le
pain de mie on se dit écolo légère ils
vont vraiment rester chez eux
déjà active dans l'industrie du barbecue
il a convaincu 2 associés et ensemble
ils ont investi près de 2 millions à
temps par des milieux beaucoup
d'opportunités gré des opportunités faut
les choisir l'appât des mis en cause une
situation très rapidement tunui a
énormément secteur et qui a aidé à
beaucoup d'autres acteurs l'entreprise
est installée dans cette usine de
drummondville depuis octobre et elle
fabrique pour le moment deux modèles ya
rien eu le plus gros permet de cuisiner
différents styles de barbecue
l'autre plus petits cible plutôt les
amateurs de plein air et l'entreprise
diversifie ses ventes en important du
charbon de bois du mix y croit on engage
les produits sont vendus au canada mais
aussi à l'international grâce à
l'expertisé de jean de vaux qui a
longtemps piloté les ventes chez meubles
canadel la logique mais pendant le
commerce international c'est la clé on
est des expériences à cause de mon passé
je reçois aux états unis ou en europe ça
va être bizarre c'est aussi une histoire
de famille puisque la femme
les deux fils de chambre evans travaille
avec lui je trouve ce gamin que ça
développe vite pied voire commun que les
personnes nième les produits qui
chaussera devoir comme auxerre ça
grandit vite
c'est extraordinaire il travaille
vraiment fort puis je généralement je
serais content que j'aille m une relève
qui relèvent de cette entreprise la pme
prévoient vendre pour 5 à 8 millions et
être rentable dès cette année elle
compte aussi lancer un ou deux nouveaux
produits par année moi je prévois de les
associer planifie déjà des
investissements supplémentaires de 2
millions pour agrandir les installations
et automatiser la production ici marie
claude morin radio-canada drummondville
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d